Susan's in New York hi Susan how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up okay so I have 35
credit cards and I own $19,000 in them
30,000 school loan which I have not paid
and this school loan was from 2009 I
still haven't paid because I'm always
putting it off how much you say 30 on
the school 30 on the school loan Chris
my husband's and I well we both went to
school and the $19,000 credit cards
now we take home 6 mm mmm
now I wanted to know I wanted to pay off
some credit cards but every week it just
seems that I'm paying something like all
minimums and it's just living paycheck
by paycheck so I wanted to know what can
I do and I mean 35 credit cards so every
week it is something should I pay off
the ones that I owe the most and the
other ones just put it for another month
are you are you ready to endure some
pain to get rid of this mess it's going
to leave us with Harley are you ready to
endure some pain to get rid of this mess
yes I am
what about your husband oh yes yes yes
okay and the two of you need to sit down
together go on every dollar calm and do
your budget tonight okay downloaded to
your iPhone or your Android or your
desktop it's free it takes about ten
minutes do your budget because what's
happening now is you guys are just
living from crisis to crisis to crisis
to crisis to crisis check comes in all
the money goes out and then you're broke
and you can't figure out how to go to
the grocery store yeah exactly
you're not living by any kind of plan
this money is owning you you don't own
it
yeah and you got to get the other side
of it and the budget helps you do that
you're telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went the
first thing that will happen when you
sit down and write out this month with
the money you have right now and you
give every dollar an assignment every
dollar a mission that's why we call it
every dollar calm the first thing that
will happen is you'll feel like you got
a raise because you're gonna go where's
all this money been going because this
organization leads to impulse and being
stressed out in desperate leads to
impulse mm-hmm and you'll quit you'll
quit going out to eat because you can't
afford to go out to eat you're at you're
done with restaurants yeah and you're
not going on vacation either don't talk
to me about a vacation you're freaking
broke yeah and then when you finish
every dollar the next thing you need to
do is get the 35 cards and put them on
the center of the table and get your
scissors out and cut up every single one
of them yeah okay every single one of
them you need plastic surgery really bad
oh yeah definitely yes now we have no
credit cards now we have to live on a
budget okay and foods first yeah so
you're gonna eat lights and water second
before you pay anybody and you take care
of the house payment third before you
pay anybody mm-hmm and you got car
payments too
no car payment we did pay off our car
yeah so that we don't want but we do
have private school we pay for my
daughter and babysitter for the baby and
now when you squeeze every dollar out of
this budget and you wring every dollar
out of it you're gonna look down and go
okay what do we got to cut out that
we're doing that we can't afford to do
anymore
and on top of what we got to cut out how
can we what can we do to increase our
income what do we got we can sell and
you start everything that's not bolted
down is gonna get sold you're not going
on vacation you're not going to a
restaurant you're taking extra jobs
you're gonna start looking at your
career I mean your whole household is
only bringing it in 60,000 and you live
in New York City that's tough yeah the
most expensive places to live in the
world and so you know and it's just it's
it's doable
buddy you ain't got a lot of wiggle room
here and that's what's been happening
and every time a disorganization should
popped up or a crisis popped up it went
onto a credit card and you were going
backwards and backwards and backwards
and backwards and backwards and you've
got to get back ahead of this thing then
we're gonna list our debts smallest to
largest and you're gonna pay off the
little one as fast as you can okay and
you're gonna cheer and dance around the
kitchen okay and then you're gonna pay
off the next one and you're gonna cheer
and you're gonna dance around the
kitchen and you're not only cheering and
dancing around the kitchen cuz you paid
off a debt you're doing it because for
the first time in your life you got
control of your money and that's what
you got to do cuz right now you feel out
of control scared and broke yeah exactly
which makes you normal and that's sad
in the school loan I just can't even
talk about the school loan well let's
get these credit cards done you don't
any credit card payments we can start
working on the school loan okay that's
the big one though and if you want to
put them on the deferment I don't care
mm-hmm let's just punch these credit
cards in the face but I mean you're
working extra you're doing everything
you can
you got one goal let's get rid of credit
card as fast as you possibly can and
I'll you know have a big garage sale
this weekend put some stuff on eBay put
some stuff on Craigslist let's turn some
stuff into money okay and turn this
around now I'm gonna send you a copy of
the book the Total Money Makeover which
is a the step-by-step game plan on
exactly how to attack this and how to do
this and you guys but your steps tonight
or every dollar calm and get your budget
done cut your credit cards up that's
your first two steps okay
and then you and your husband are in
agreement we're going to sacrifice
deeply because I am so sick of living
like this yeah and when you get sick and
tired of sick and tired you're ready to
change your life kiddo yeah you can you
can do it and you call me back if you
need help okay
okay thank you Dave all right you hold
on I'll have Kelly pick up I'm gonna
give you a Christmas present it's the
Total Money Makeover book merry
Christmas to you this is the Christmas
you changed your life are you ready set
go hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
you
[Music]